sur le premier point une ambiance de
terreur les révélations d'un pilier de
l'émission le premier point charge du
documentaire c'est cette interview d'une
personne présentée comme un pilier de
l'émission une personne qui connaîtrait
tous les rouages de TPMP une personne
qu'on a même pas vu en silhouette qui a
été doublé en fait c'est ils ont pris un
comédien pour faire la doublure du gars
et il a ils ont doublé sa voix ça veut
dire que on peut dire que c'est on sait
pas qui c'est
voilàe personne ne peut imaginer ce
qu'on
vit me dit pourquoi vous restez mais
c'est c'est le principe d'un gourou
c'est très difficile d'en sortir parce
qu'il vous fait comprendre que vous êtes
une merde que personne vous récupère et
vous finissez par le croire parce qu'il
vous menace physiquement aussi quand un
chroniqueur dit quelque chose qui ne lui
plaît pas il peut recevoir un texto qui
dit tu ne seras pas là la semaine
prochaine et d'un coup comme ça il peut
enlever 5 jours de salaire à quelqu'un
non mais e c'est énorme ça c'est le
meilleur pour moi c'est un des meilleurs
vous ne savez pas ce qu'on vit c'est
guanamo ici dit non mais s rigol non
mais les gars quand vous voyez ça juste
franchement quelqu'un veut réagir
là-dessus c'est incroyable et oui mais
parce que en fait moi comment tu peux
croire ça en plus mais oui surtout on n
pas on n pas point et main lié si j'ai
envie de me barrer je me barre quoi
c'est un moment je suis pas content des
conditions si je suis pas content ça tu
peux pas dire vous savez pas ce qu'on
vit non mais c'est et cette personne là
je sais pas qui c'est je vous le dis
mais cette personneel il faut qu'elle se
rende compte vous rendez compte qu'il y
a des gens savez vous savez ce qu'il
font vous savez ce qu'ils font ils se
réveillent à 6h du matin s'occuper
d'enfants parfois en difficulté ils
rentent chez eux à 19h ils gagnent 600 €
par mois ou 800 € par mois ça c'est des
gars qui viennent ils sont payés je le
dis entre 500 et 1000 € par émission ils
viennent pour poser leur cul 3 heur sur
une chaise et pour donner leur avis sur
l'actualité ils sont au chaud ils sont
maquillés ils sont coiffés et ils disent
vous savez pas ce qu'on vit mais quand
mais je suis journaliste moi le mec qui
me dit ça au téléphone je dis mais vous
foutez de ma gueule vous savez pas ce
qu'on vit tu prends 15 boules par mois
tu viens t'asseoir ton cul sur une
chaise pendant 3 He VI te maquiller on
te rembourse les restaurants tu es
habillé tu es coiffé et tu viens me
casser les couilles non mais les gars
non mais quand on entend ça c'est
indécent je suis désolé moi moi la
journaliste elle entend ça je lui dis
écoutez c'est pas possible de d'écouter
ça je suis désolé et et et quand on dit
rendez compte et il dit ouais s'il y a
quelque chose qui lui a pas plu et il
nous dit tu seras pas là demain mais
écoutez il m'arrive de dire à des
chroniqueurs oui tu seras pas là demain
parce que parfois je change l'équipe et
parce que parfois je trouve qu'un
chroniqueur n'est pas bon pendant de TR
qure émissions moi je suis comme un
sélectionneur Didier Deschamp c'est un
amour de gars dans la vie et c'est un
mec hyper droit Didier je peux vous le
dire mais parfois il a des choix à faire
et il sélectionne telle ou telle
personne non mais c'est ça non mais en
plus non mais rendez compte et on peut
ne pas avoir de salaire pendant 5 jours
mais même pendant 5 jours sans ton
salaire tu gagnes plus que tous les
Français pratiquement tu gagnes plus que
90 % des Français donc
euh ça c'est n'importe quoi euh il y
avait un bonus c'est le placement des
chroniqueurs n'importe quoi aussi euhe
cé Plô pas
mal la première place à droite c'est son
copilote donc c'est son meilleur c'est
celui qui regarde pour voir si ces V
sont drles ou pas
drôles l'invité est à droite les
meilleurs chroniqueurs sont à droite et
de l'autre côté à
gauche il y a g Janton qui dit pas un
mot c'est vraiment la droite l'important
la dernière place on appelle ça la place
de la potiche c'est toujours une belle
fille qui l'occupe c'est delphineper
Kelly
c'est une place intéressante car il y a
beaucoup de caméras donc quand on fait
un large elle est tout de suite dessus
non mais pa aujourd'hui non mais c'est
n'importe quoi ça ve dire ça veut dire
que mon copilote c'est Bernard
Monti merci j'adore Bernard mais non non
mais mais et puis là ce côté je dis pas
que ce côté n'est pas fort mais ce côté
il y a Gill verd des piliers de
l'émission il a Galine en vrai il y a de
piliers éor P de
[Rires]
l'émissionut
d'ailleurs r il est parfois de l'aut
côté
aussi est
plusent il parle de l'année dernière ça
tout es dit les gens qui regardent
l'émission quand tu entends le mec qui
te dit je pas qui guignle pas guignole
je sais pas d'où il sort jeis pas plein
je sais pas sil est venu il dit
Guillaume Ganton ne dit pas un mot
Guillaume Ganton ne dit pas un mot non
mais il faut les regarder les émissions
par et tu démarres souvent même par
Guillaume des fois il faut qu'il regarde
les émissions ce mec là alors on vous a
on a parlé aussi hier cette même source
anonyme qui affirme je dicterai au
chroniqueurs que je dicterai au
chroniqueurs ce qu' doivent dire dans
l'émission Le Soir regardez c'est
insupportable ça on a demandé à l'équipe
de débattre sur la peine de mort
évidemment tous les chroniqueurs étaient
contre donc Cyr est rentré dans la salle
et il a dit il n'y aura pas de débat ça
fait chier il a dit démerdez-vous j'en
veux deux qui soi pour tout est faux
c'est ça qui est assez marrant avant de
passer en plateau leurs interventions
leur sont dictées au mot près ou presque
il faut absolument que tu dis Arthur va
se servir de ce qu'on dit pour signer
une saison 2 de district Z moi je dois
dire ça oui ça c'est que toi je me
demande s'il fait pas ça de parler
d'acharnement de harcèlement et cetera
pour essayer d'aller négocier une saison
2 auprès de TF1 mais si c'est incroyable
c'est incroyable ça c'est génial bon là
il faut être clair quand même là là on
est dans le délire c'estàdire qu'on est
dans le dans le fantasme absolu
c'est non j'ai sur la forme j'ai sur la
forme F là on est dans le délire par
exemple moi je prends mon exemple je
bosse le matin je dès qu'on a les sujets
je demande de les avoir ensuite je
commence à travailler l'après-midi je
dis j'ai des infos sur ça je n'ai aucun
contact avec Cyril je n'ai aucun contact
éditorial avec Cyril je n'ai aucun mais
personne ne m'a jamais dit vous imaginez
que quelqu'un va me dire de prononcer
des mots qui vont me valoir des tombau
d'insultes sur les réseaux sociaux Cyril
me rentre dedans il ne sait même pas ce
que je vais dire donc là il faut dire
aux gens moi j'ai travaillé dans plein
de médias presse écrite le Parisien
l'équipe des télés tout ça la liberté
que j'ai ici je ne l'ai jamais eu nulle
part donc là je le dis clairement il y a
une liberté totale on dit ce qu'on pense
parfois ça dérange mais il y a jamais eu
une intervention de votre part pour me
dire de quoi que ce soit et encore une
fois on ne discute pas d'or et parfois
quand vous dites G a des infos c'est
parce que j'ai dit à la pro de
l'après-midi sur ce fait d'hiver là j'ai
eu des trucs vous pouvez le dire à cy
c'est tout mais il ne sait pas ce que
j'ai parfois il m'arrive et je le dis de
leur donner des inf médiia que j'ai moi
donc je leur dis je vais vous les donner
comme ça vous parfois on laisse tomber
des sujets parce qu'on est tous d'accord
et le sujet tombe parce que justement on
est tous d'accord et qu'on se dit qu'il
y aura pas de débat non mais ça voilà ça
c hement ce passage là c'est de la
diffamation franchement moi je je l' bon
on va pas les les attaquer c'est plutô
du fantasme non ENF dire qu'on a tous
une une une une feuille de route écrite
à l'avance pard cl précise je dire voilà
mais moi par exemple c'est la première
fois que je viens ici on Mo jeenvoyé les
sujets et personne m'a rien dit personne
m'a dit de dire ça
ou on l'a remarqué
hein non mais en plus je trouve que je
trouve ça surréaliste parce que eux qu
dans le monde du journalisme tout est
écrit à l'avance un journal tout est
écrit tu à 19h30 le rédacteur en chef il
sait parfaitement ce qu'il y a dans son
journal et moi c'est ça a été c'est la
première fois que je fais que je
participe à une émission dans lequel il
y a du divertissement direct c'est au
contraire il y a quelque chose de très
euh très spontané très très très voilà
tout est imprévu donc oui on a un
conducteur mais au milieu de ce
conducteur là on sait très bien comment
tu réagis tu peux faire plein de choses
très différen à
voir alors les chéres on va revenir sur
on on on a beaucoup de points à voir et
vous attendez les réponses bien sûr à
toutes les questions et notamment le
bateau qui
arrive au bout de 15 minutes 15 minutes
de l'enquête aussi diffuse un témoignage
vraiment hyper trop important celui de
Jessie claire présenté comme une
ancienne chroniqueuse il vient dénoncer
ce qui se passe ici France 2 donc donne
de la crédibilité une meuf qui a fait
quatre émissions trois avec moi et une
avec Julien Courbet est allé sur un mois
6 jours et sur 12 ans d'émission quand
même on a les dates de ces apparitions
31 mai 2017 2 juin 2017 16 juin 2017 et
6 juillet 2017 c'était sans moi c'était
avec Julien Courbet pour vous dire
qu'ils ont essayer de nous vendre un
truc de ouf pour walou sur ce sur ce sur
ce sujet là regardez Jess CLIRE moi ça
me mettait la pression d'être en
présence de Cyril pourquoi la pression
honnêtement ma peur d'être humilié tout
le temps à partir de ma première
émission c'est pas que j'avais une
petite prière mais presque de me dire
fait qu'il se passe rien de grave
aujourd'hui et que mon image soit soit
respectée qu'est-ce que vous pouvez dire
sur elle est splendide c'est tout vous
fraîche dans ma tête ça tourne à 3000 et
je me dis c'est
exactement tout ce que je ne voulais pas
je suis d'entrée de jeu dans les
premières secondes le nouveau bout de
viande infysique quoi on sait très bien
qu'on est là pour faire le show mais en
même temps moi j'ai j'avais pas signé du
tout pour ça déjà un physique bon ça va
E melon non mais c'est vrai voilà
Valérie justement ils ont essayé de nous
faire passer pour des des misogynes des
sexistes c'est eux qui sont pr le V pas
pas apprécié parce que alors on fait
dire à cette fameuse voix off pas voix
off pardon mais à ce fameux témoin qui a
vu l'homme qui a vu l'homme qui a vu
l'ours que alors la la place ici c'est
la place de la potiche et à chaque fois
en fait le rôle des femmes c'est
toujours dégradant c'estàd que moi par
exemple je suis celle qui rit
c'ests bneis très F ets mais comme je r
Je ne pense
pasyz c'est Kelly qui est là souvent
Kelly la
potiche niveau
[Musique]
caractère c'est pas ce qui se fait de
plus
facile est d'c en revanche pour s'amuse
énormément et qu'on est du second degré
pardon mais le second degré c'est livré
avec
l'intelligence qu on est une jolie fille
on est une Poti
pour
JIS il regarde Kelly c'est tout sauf une
potiche ça veut dire c'est c'est ça veut
dire quand même la jolie fille qui est
làbas pe pas jolie et
intelligon s étaitil était une meuf et
belle voilà en fait c'est VO mais même
si oui c'est une jolie fille qui est au
bout la table à chaque fois et et alors
c'est une
organisation oua non mais cette place là
oui c'est vrai on va pas le nier c'est
souvent la Jol fille mais quand quand tu
es jolie donc tu es forcément
conne comme si Moch était intelligent